New York City struggled to meet its recruitment
goals during the spring of 1917.
The United States had recently entered World
War I, which had been raging in Europe since
1914 (see: What Really Started WWI), and the
military needed volunteers.
While New York City had a population of around
6.5 million at the time, it lagged behind
its goal of 2,000 recruits to the United States
Navy by under half.
So New York City’s Mayor, John P. Mitchel,
decided that he needed a gimmick to spark
young men’s interest and convince them to
volunteer for the war.
What better way to draw attention to the Navy
than to construct a battleship in the middle
of Union Square?
Teaming up with the Navy on the project, the
Mayor’s Committee on National Defense raised
approximately $10,000 (about $187,000 today)
to fund the ship and hired Jules Guerin and
Donn Barber to design the appropriately named
USS Recruit, basing the design loosely on
the USS Maine.
With work rapidly completed by the U.S. Navy,
the USS Recruit, also known as the Landship
Recruit, was built on the island of Manhattan.
Construction finished for a “launch” on
May 30, 1917, with the ship being christened
by Olive Mitchel, the Mayor’s wife.
(See: Why We Break A Bottle of Champagne Against
New Ships)
The wooden battleship mockup measured over
200 feet long and had a beam, or width, of
40 feet.
While not actually armed for battle, the ship
featured wooden replicas of two cage masts,
six 14-inch guns inside three twin turrets,
and ten 5-inch guns.
It also had two 50-foot masts, an 18-foot
tall smokestack, a main bridge, and a conning
tower.
recruitThe Landship Recruit contained ample
space for the job of recruiting and training
sailors, with multiple waiting rooms and physical
exam rooms, complete with full amenities.
Doctors, officers, and sailors lived aboard
the ship in their separate quarters.
As for the latter, the initial complement
was thirty-nine sailors-in-training from the
Newport Training Station and their commander,
Captain C.F. Pierce.
The crew maintained a similar routine to the
one of a crew at sea.
As reported by Popular Science Magazine in
August of 1917,
recruit3
The land sailors arise at six o’clock, scrub
the decks, wash their clothes, attend instruction
classes, and then stand guard and answer questions
for the remainder of the day.
There is a night as well as a day guard.
From sunup to eleven o’clock all lights
of the ship are turned on, including a series
of searchlight projectors.
In addition to recruiting volunteers for the
Navy and training new sailors, the USS Recruit
served as a public relations tool.
Citizens were invited onto the ship to learn
about then modern battleships, and the sailors
aboard routinely answered the public’s questions
during their guard duty.
Both patriotic and social events were also
held on the battleship with the sailors acting
as hosts.
One patriotic event, according to a contemporary
account from The New York Times, was the presentation
of a recreation of Betsy Ross’s American
flag.
Other events were just social in nature, such
as dances held for New York’s social elite.
There were reportedly even Vaudeville shows
held on board.
recruit4World War I ended in November of 1918
when both Austria-Hungary and Germany agreed
to an armistice while the terms of peace could
be negotiated.
However, the USS Recruit continued its recruitment
mission until March of 1920.
It had helped the Navy recruit an astounding
25,000 new sailors (enough to man the USS
Maine, which the Recruit was loosely modeled
after, a whopping 45 times over) during its
three years of operation.
At this time, the Navy announced that it would
move the wooden battleship from Union Square
to Luna Park on Coney Island and maintain
it as a recruitment site there.
The New York Times described the “sailing”
of the Recruit in an article on March 17,
1920:
Yesterday when 10 o’clock came around and
with it ‘sailing time’ all of the ceremonies
were put on.
The crew of eighty men lined up on the quarterdeck
and the ship was formally abandoned while
the Stars and Stripes and the commissioned
pennant were hauled down.
The ship’s band struck up ‘The Star-Spangled
Banner’ as the colors were lowered to the
deck.
recruit2The ship was then carefully dismantled
over the course of a few days, with the pieces
shipped off to Coney Island.
Though The New York Times estimated that it
would take just two weeks for the Navy to
complete the move of the battleship, it was
never rebuilt.
Out of sight, out of mind, no contemporary
news source seems to have bothered to cover
why the ship, which was supposed to be immediately
rebuilt, was not.
What happened to the pieces of the dismantled
ship is also a mystery to this day.
A search through the Navy archives for the
period in question likewise turned up nothing
insightful concerning the ship’s demise.
Presumably it was simply decided at the last
minute that rebuilding and maintaining the
ship was an unnecessary expense given the
Navy’s recruitment needs at the time.
While this was the end of the Union Square
battleship, it would not be the end of the
name in the U.S. Navy.
The USS Recruit (AM-285) was launched in 1943
and served during WWII before being decommissioned
in 1946 and ultimately sold to the Mexican
Navy in 1963.
Following this, another landlocked ship was
built, the USS Recruit (TDE-1), at the San
Diego Naval Training Center in 1949.
Built to scale at two-thirds the size of a
Dealey-class destroyer escort, the ship was
made of wood with sheet metal overlay and
was used to train tens of thousands of recruits
over the coming decades.
It was, however, decommissioned in 1967, funny
enough, because it could not be classified
in the Navy’s new computerized registry.
However, commissioned or not, it was in continuous
service from 1949 to 1997 (with a complete
re-model in 1982) when the base it is on was
closed.
While no longer being used, the ship still
stands, with some thought to perhaps turning
it into a maritime museum at some point.